[Music]
this time you see a teenager we will
kill it
wait wait
watching Andrews no we only look young
but but really we're 40.
[Music]
they're aged yeah I mean we we eat young
Souls all the time that's well just like
you guys that's what we brought you back
you are our idols
[Laughter]
and great news you don't even have to
brew the potions anymore you could just
buy them oh buy them buy them yes we
have we have a whole Youth and beauty
industry you know shops where you can go
buy all sorts of serums and and lotions
of lotions like potions potions
we already drank the life potions
we're wasting time we must fly
on what
just like my old one
what about us there's only one that
that's fine something anything we must
behaving
um
[Music]
I'll do it they were the only roomies
left the man said be careful they have a
mind of their own he's right
it's just us Focus we must slide while
our ancestral Cottage get book and Brew
our potion then what we did then we run
a mock and Salem
don't make me come over there with this
broom
[Music]
that's not Six Feet Under
who are you
zombie stop I am a good zombie I'm not
even chasing Dave stay back
and don't try to eat my brains why would
I I simply wish to know why you were
digging up my grave and I simply wish to
know why you're alive but because I was
woken up and never put back to sleep
well I've been awake since
how long ago was 1993
[Music]
forever
[Music]
there were rights to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting happy 16th
birthday child
a gift from my favorite customers
Legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her powers
Gilbert where did you get that candle we
have to get out of here which it'll be
here any seconds
the book is alive he woke up
if we intend to live past Sunrise we
have to steer this so so whoa whoa wait
can we talk about this no
we must fly
freak out if a mental Maniac obsessed
with getting revenge on Salem so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
zombie
remember when you remember remember oh I
love that I thought I was brilliant in
that I'm sorry I'm not supposed to say
that
sorry what was your next question
look have a glorious morning
makes me sick when it is my favorite
character that I ever played she's so
out there
I love playing Sarah
I get to be with two extraordinarily
gifted comedic actors and get to sing
and be absurd and silly my favorite part
of the first one was the Flying
we didn't expect much of it even though
it had a blast making it it wasn't long
before it was a this phenomenon
[Applause]
it's you know very special to be part of
something that has become so meaningful
to people it's a wonderful surprise to
everybody
I wish I had a nickel for every time I
see a Winnie costume online
[Music]
they were so into it they knew every
line they knew every ad-lib they'd say
remember when you said I smell children
find the book Brew the potion and suck
our eyes out of the social available
sunrise
foreign
thing about seeing all three of them
together for the first time in hair
makeup wardrobe is that they immediately
embodied their characters I think for
all of us it was not a difficult
transition to step back into those
booths that was the moment that I was in
awe and and stunned that I was even
participating in any way shape or form
it felt that special
[Music]
[Music]
the movie event fans have been wanting
for nearly 30 years a highly anticipated
Hocus Pocus sequel now the sisters are
back to their delightfully Wicked tricks
what was behind it for me the whole time
respect of the first one bring in the
Nostalgia that I truly think is the
heart and soul of why this movie has
lasted as long as it has
I think it's one of the greatest joys of
my life
so fast
[Music]
hey happy birthday thanks so what are
you guys doing tonight
our therapist roll scary movie marathon
Santa's over here
you know Legend has it it's on the 16th
birthday that a witch gets her powers
another year begins anew
Maiden mother and chrome too
call on the one request
to help our intentions manifest
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's the Sanderson sisters I bet
you're looking for the stage
always
[Music]